oh no this is about the father this is
about the son Artemis Fowl this is your
first major leading role so how does it
feel to see your face on billboards and
commercials on TV
yeah mazing I'm like you when you see us
you kind of do a double-take you see it
and then you're like whoa
talk to me yeah it's really surreal I'm
seeing yourself up there and also I was
much younger when I was doing it so it's
really weird to see a younger version of
myself all around me it's really cool
you've grown strong son and smarter but
I ever imagined come take me with you
to get our audiences better acquainted
with you fer do what is something about
you most people wouldn't realize I like
all aspects of film actually I'm
involved with a thumb group where we
direct we edit we act we we do all the
script for mouthing it's really cool but
yeah I like all aspects go ahead on
Thomas I'm scared to dirty
an army is coming
there are many famous faces in this film
so was there any one you were most
looking forward to me the cast is
absolutely phenomenal in this film and
definitely
I've always loved film so getting to
meet Dame Judi Dench was so surreal for
me too the fact to the point where I
cried when I first met her I just
couldn't believe that she was a real
person standing in front of me and then
when I met Josh GAD I loved Josh's work
for so long from his book of mormon days
and to frozen to beating the beast
everything in between
so I'm fruity I can tell you this and he
was there when I first met Josh my face
went completely red and I forgot how to
speak so definitely I think all the cast
involved
I mean you couldn't ask for a better
cast now speaking of Judi Dench she
called you the real deal
Lara so how does that feel to hear oh my
god oh my goodness I mean I mean do you
hear that at all is such a compliment
but to hear it from Dame Judi Dench that
is so incredible and it just she's the
kindest person ever she I have no words
what is each of your favorite memory of
working with Judi and Josh the first
time we ever met Judy after we were
introduced to her by Kenneth Branagh and
we made fairy cakes with her which is
have you made fairy cakes with Dame Judi
Dench which is one of the most bizarre
and surreal stories ever but we got to
discuss the film and we got to discuss
our characters and different aspects and
details of the film while making fairy
cakes which is definitely an incredible
moment for both of us and then Josh
personally for me and Josh knew that I
had done some musical theater work and
he was familiar with the musical that I
had worked in and on one of the first
days that we were filming together in
the middle of the scene he began singing
one of the songs from the musical which
had me an absolute fits of laughter so
that's definitely a favorite for me yeah
I would say say memory with Judi I'm
just thinking fairy cakes because we got
the recipe wrong as well and they can
turn to sludge but it was such it was
such a nice intro to nature I'm rather
than just meeting her straight on set
and getting straight to it it was just
nice to kind of get comfortable another
um I like everything with Josh I heart
was
ridiculous the odd lips everything honey
was the funniest thing ever working with
him we were all just if it's about their
just every scene I'm such great never
told me how to start but he may have
told me how to end and yeah he read the
same poem to me every night before bed
and every time you left may the road
rise up to meet you may the wind be
always at your back may the Sun Shine
warm upon your face may the rains fall
soft upon your fields who wrote this
poem auntie
nobody knows that's just it
Artemis is an intelligent gifted
youngster so what might you both
consider yourself exceptionally good at
I'm not exceptionally good on anything I
don't think I like to be he's
exceptionally good at most things I'd
like to be I like to be good at a lot of
things I like to spread spread my
goodness spread his talents I really
don't know and something that my
favorite subject in school is English
and I feel like I can I can really
analyze the Shakespeare player I would
say that's something I exceptionally fit
oh that's a good old Shakespeare on
script writing we are we made of foam on
sax at one point we're just all the cost
members
well like the a kid I'm in tutoring I'm
Laura wrote the script and it was really
cool
I'm sure do you direct I'm pretty
directed it so this yeah was there any
like antics or pranks on set between you
guys and Josh and Judi
we were always messing around yeah you
take it too seriously it was just like
onset of series but in tutoring nobody
we took school very seriously what are
you talking about okay seriously I
didn't breathe much on trolls anything
else to do cake for the teeth
people could - no what would you both
say is the takeaway from this film and
personally for me although this story is
and absolutely it's so adventurous it's
full of magic and fantasy and mythical
creatures and other worlds that I think
is something that we all love to see
although it is filled with that there is
a core message at the end of it and that
is no matter where we come from that we
are similar in different ways for
example even though Irish mist comes
from the human world and Holi comes from
the fairy world's the two when they
first meet each other don't want
anything to do with each other they're
from different worlds they don't want to
do anything they are repulsed by each
other in fact but when they start to get
to know each other better they realize
that they have more things in common
than they thought they did and I think
that's one of the core messages of the
film is that no matter where we come
from who we are we should never judge a
person by the way for our first
impressions that we should always wait
to get to know them because we all do
have things in common at the end of the
day I can't really say more than that I
think Clara captured up perfectly it's
just the mix between the 13 human worlds
I'm the way they they start off on edge
at each other but after a while they
just realize that there's more of the
same type of person you know with Holly
and Artemis they discover their fathers
that we have both been captured you know
they work together aside from their
differences they still work together
I'm the next criminal mastermind
this is what they call greatness
[Music]